so first off I gotta ask you because you  are a governor and today McCain picked  this governor do you know her I mean did  you run into her at a governor's meeting  or maybe idea do you know the other  governors cuz we don't know anything  about her what can you tell us about her  yeah I've met governor Palin just once  or twice don't know her well but you  know congratulate her on getting picked  I think the choice says interesting  things about Senator McCain what I saw  today was that he had only talked to her  once last February in person called her  on the cell phone during the Alaska  State Fair last week and decided to  offer her the job I mean it's only to be  a heartbeat away from the presidency so  that struck me as a little impulsive but  you know you make a statement about  yourself when you make a pic like that I  think it's I think it says a lot that  you're just giving the facts and getting  big laughs  [Applause]